i still don't have to go through it if
it's wrong but like
there's levels there's little but also
it's like getting back to it it's like
you really hear about all this stuff now
and you're like
whoa but there's also in terms of
someone like louie
there's got to be a road to redemption
and this is one of the problems with
people that are so
[ __ ] angry is that they don't think
there's any road to redemption they want
his career to be taken away should never
play again but the michael vick thing is
different
because michael vick tortured and
murdered didn't murder
the state said you would need to do this
for what he did he
served his time he's lost his freedom
for four years yes
yes so his job that he had before has
nothing to do with it but it does come
down to
people going i i'm not through with you
suffering yet
okay same thing with literally i still
think it's a difference i'm not through
with you suffering you represent kill
evil to women and torturing people
do you represent evil to women just
because he beat off he's a
representative of a vapor they're not
of course you're just a creeper but like
not even that i don't think but like
but like pervert i guess what are you
i don't know man it's actually deviant
you hang out with two girls who are like
talking dirty for two days you go on
drinks with them
you start getting like the idea it's
like i think i can hook up i think i
might have a threesome
and they're like that's not enough
reason to go for it's like yeah you're
right i need more signs
like well let me say you want to go out
for drinks and i do it's like still no
it's not enough for
of the signs like yeah you're right
you're right oh i know i'll invite them
up to my hotel room
that's usually a pretty universal sign
and they're coming they came to my hotel
room
no that's not enough you're right you're
right you're right all these signs is
not enough
tell you what i'll just ask outright can
i [ __ ] jerk off in front of you and
they said yes
no that's still not enough what are you
talking about
well here's the so no not creeper but he
represents things to people
yes just like roseanne represented trump
when she said she has a character voted
for trump in this in the show
so because they're representative evil
against women they go just get rid of
that representative
right and they're not seeing him as a
human being that people actually
know right that is a human as a person
not only that
if someone says yes if you ask
can i beat off in front of you and they
say yes and then never say no no i was
just kidding just
leave the yes out there here's this
we're done here we're done
did you say yes okay so like if a girl
says can i
can i play with my [ __ ] in front of you
and you go yeah and then she doesn't go
well that was [ __ ] disgusting and i
can't believe this happened and i'm
going right to the press
like wait a minute did you say yes yeah
like
okay here's one thing is if this is an
aggressive angry person who traps you to
room you feel like the only way you can
get out
the only way you can get out of this
room is you let this guy beat off in
front of you and you're
you're fearful of your life people don't
really most people don't really care
i i saw them on stage everyone clapped
like crazy they were so happy and when
he goes
guys i'm just going to do jokes tonight
everyone's like [ __ ] yes
yeah just do jokes two jokes we just
want to see what we loved about you two
years ago
yeah ten months ago yeah and michael
vick we just want you to see you throw
we're done with that you did your crime
or we still hate you
there's nothing wrong with mike richards
how you got your job
he didn't he just got he just yelled out
racist [ __ ] but like but like nobody
nobody saw nobody liked him on stage but
the thing yeah you're right so it's like
i'm missing about
louis is you know you there's got to be
some path of redemption for everybody
yeah for everybody i mean
human beings very well can bill cosby
no not go up at a prison
talent show no no no
it's over can't even go up in
prison no disagree no
i'm kidding until you show me the
connection
to what he did versus this job you know
i mean if you pete rose bet on baseball
he hurt the job he was doing so that
you're like you can't be in baseball
anymore because you [ __ ] over baseball
but did he [ __ ] over baseball by betting
on it yeah he
they show he like probably threw some
games through some games or he like used
his relievers in situations he wouldn't
have that he can't use them tomorrow
because
you [ __ ] over baseball that [ __ ] up
so you basically don't know anything
has shut its doors to you right if you
steal jokes
yes you maybe there is a path to
redemption
maybe but you [ __ ] over jokes well you
[ __ ] over other comments yes
so you [ __ ] over the experience you're
talking about getting back into but that
guy can go
to the supermarket yes he can work at
another job because it has nothing you
haven't shown me a connection
to another job see the thing about the
joke stealing thing
and this is where it gets really really
weird is
there's no real punishment other than
people deciding they don't like you
because you're a joke thief so that is
the real punishment
like you're talking like on twitter take
you down it's like no no what i'm saying
is it's different than someone who
steals cars
right someone steals cars there's a
punishment set up yeah you go to jail
it's illegal
if someone steals jokes like you've
basically done the same thing you've
stolen a thing
you know that thing is ethereal the
thing yeah
it's also a little different because you
can still do your jokes
if i steal your car you can't have your
car no no no no if somebody goes on in
front of you
like we know mancia did yeah and does
your headline
your closing bit on purpose on purpose
to [ __ ] with you he would do closing
bits
the best was freddy [ __ ] with bobby
once and he was like oh you're going to
love him i mean he would [ __ ] with bobby
bobby yeah but it wasn't a steal yeah it
was to [ __ ] with bobby
you're gonna love this next guy he's so
funny and bobby all he wanted was
freddie's support
he looked up to him so hard and he could
never get it
you're gonna love this next guy who does
this joke about selling corn on the side
of the road he's like yelling corny
corner yells
so good he has us a little bit about
about his dad you tell his [ __ ]
he would just tell the the ending punch
lines
do that just pull his legs out from
under him that's a terrible thing
i mean he was [ __ ] with him but he
wasn't doing to gain himself
only to hurt bobby and only in one
moment that i ever saw but it was like
[ __ ] you got me bad
hmm yeah i mean they were bitter enemies
it was like they beat our enemies
something about ratting routing them out
to somebody
a long time before the argument's way
going yeah it's done
but like they hated each other back then
um
freddie hated bobby bobby hated him back
only because
the thing about people getting caught
it's like the punishment's
real though it's almost better than
going to jail yeah it's like we don't we
we know about you now not only do we
know about you now but the public knows
about you now
and the disdain is palpable yeah it's
real and you see it not just with him
not just with mencia but
there's a few of them and you can tell
the difference too between somebody
going
that guy took that guy's joke versus
that guy takes jokes
you know i mean that guy took that guy
that's out there and that's real right
but it doesn't quite stick as much as
like we all just know that guy steals
jokes right
you know yeah well it's not a possible
like it's like over and over again like
there's such a clarity too and the
difference between the jokes they come
up with on their own
and the jokes that they steal and sure
you can keep going up you can still
settle theaters
so your punishment is we know about you